today we're gonna play some ipad we're
playing alf alpaca i have no idea what
this game is but it looked amazing
so
there's a bunch of llamas i don't know
why i don't know what to do i don't know
anything i'm clicking on him
fantastic so we're
for a llama
killing other llamas
i keep hitting them
and i level up
okay am i eating i'm about to level up
all right i'll level up what happens
oh my god this is like pokemon he's
evolving
he evolved to smoking alpaca no he's
taking a [ __ ] alpaca what is oh he can
run now oh my god that's that's my dream
right there i'm oh he's smoking again
nice uh camel toe you got there alpaca
what the [ __ ] is this game how do i
level up there's another one kill it
[ __ ] get off my turf i'll [ __ ]
you up what the hell am i doing what is
that animation
are they merging with my i think they're
merging with my body
come on level up
yes
what's gonna happen
i'm evolving two super bro alpaca
so bro oh my gosh smash them to pieces
get inside me
do you even llama bro this is probably
the best game of the century do you have
a llama bruh come inside me bro
oh yeah bro i gotta say the story is
really breathtaking in this game
it almost makes me teary-eyed
my life was filled with nothing but
sorrow and melancholy but now
i finally can feel love again thank you
alpaca
thank you
this game has taken over my life oh my
god so many alpacas gotta go them inside
me so fast
yes yes oh oh oh what is happening oh so
many nipples oh my god i got muscle on
top of my muscles
oh my god oh oh
oh
why don't they care that i'm murdering
all their friends i don't understand
the great mysteries of the alpaca why do
you have four arms no one knows but one
thing's for certain he must inject more
uppercase
two thousand years later oh my god it's
happening
what's gonna happen
oh my god
no
what is that
alpaca
my boobs are alphas
i'm pretty sure this is the high point
of my life how does even
hello he's struggling to walk
too many alphaquest i have an alpha on
my neck that is fine this is [ __ ] up
man how long is this game like i've been
playing forever seriously what the [ __ ]
this game is slowly taking over my life
must consume more abacus this rpg is the
[ __ ] hardest grind i ever had man
jesus
they just take forever to spawn a few
inches later oh my god we're so close
come on
come on one more oh
oh my god
it's happening it's happening i can't
believe it's happening
oh my god it's checking why is it
shaking oh god that grotesque monster
where will it stop
when will it ever stop alpha cat alpaca
fees for more alpha blood kill them all
oh god what is that i don't know what
just happened but oh god it's jake oh no
he's shaking the real question is when
i'm gonna stop playing oh god never
never i'm gonna stop what is he doing
oh god he's feasting on them yes
i'm pretty sure this is how miley cyrus
was born malfucka
the heartbringer of death they don't
mind dying they come here to be
sacrificed through the also mighty alpha
calorie i've been playing for over an
hour
this game has really been an eye opener
for me as to how [ __ ] up japan is
i knew that already
one more round of alpacas should do it
our lord and savior will reveal his next
form
oh my god i can't brace myself
here he comes
one more yes oh my god
he can speak oh no lord alpaca i'm not
oh my god what is he doing
of course
of course
it may all makes oh god what is he doing
tumbling oh my god he's
he's doing all kinds of things
oh great mighty alpha tries unicycle
two hours later okay this is so much fun
i am having the time of my life
i love this game so much
oh more alphabet please smart oh god no
more
ah
where did the unicycle go
nobody knows i'm a nipple machine so it
doesn't matter
uh go inside me
is it me or is it slightly getting
nighttime in the game several bad puns
later
yes yes
what's happening
what is going on
now
what is going on
what is happening what is this i'm
freaking out what the hell is that
hi ba
how about
no
what are you doing
don't kill up a lord
kill the alpha peasants they're the ones
to blame
no
what am i supposed to do
no
no
alpha
no
what
he can he can still he can still
what but
oh my god alpha no i could destroy alpha
no one ain't nobody eat them all
you [ __ ] the alpha god will rise
as the prophecy foretold
five million helpers before
the best [ __ ] game i have ever played
eat them all
we will pay
ladies
three weeks later almost there up
the lord will rise there it is one more
oh
god
when will it stop
when will it end i want it to stop now
alpha angels [ __ ] you
oh god what are you doing to them
oh god oh god uh alphaload
one hour later
one eternity later eat them all
show no mercy oh
yes
power
more power suck the man with your
alpha vagina he just looks for power now
why why does he need power oh my god oh
my god the power is maximum out what
what
what who are you
who are dao i always wondered how you
look like god
but now i know what do i do now i'm
clicking on him
sparkles
i unleash my power upon god
wait am i supposed to kill god
unleash the power of families only alpha
cat is strong enough to overthrown god
power meter go
shoot
yes
so much that
a subjugated population that represent
power but it doesn't necessarily equal
happiness absorb god
well of course
of course we'll absorb god do it
what the [ __ ] are those guys doing there
what the [ __ ] were they
what is this what is this what is this
what is this oh no my exp oh yeah it
goes up thank goodness oh
all right
all right now
all right i've seen it all now
the alpaca became a garden he'll
probably go on absorbing every living
thing that is born according to his
desire forever that didn't matter at all
oh
oh
okay then
it's beautiful
beautiful
alpaca
it's you and me baby
it was you and me all along
you're welcome
you're goddamn welcome
we became all the chromosomes in the
universe
best game ever
best game [ __ ] ever made i i what am
i supposed to do now this was the
highlight of my life
give it a thumbs up if you enjoyed
watching of course you did
see you tomorrow bravest bye